you
[Music]
so in order to give some context of
where spark fits when you're doing data
analysis in our it's it makes sense to
ask this question right like if you have
slow code what do you do and you know
like it could be slow code because
you're dealing with a lot of data you
could also be slow for other reasons
right so the answer is definitely not
spark at least not not as an entry point
you know one of the techniques that you
can use is just sample data right like
if you have a lot of data you can reduce
the amount of data that you have and you
know as long as you do it properly and
you know you use you can use techniques
like it statistical sampling or why not
reduce the amount of data that you have
and that definitely is progress in the
right direction another technique that
you can use when you have slow code is
in the same way that yo Chang was
presenting in the keynote this morning
you can use prophecies right so if
something slow you can look at why is it
slow it might be the case that it's your
code or it's a package you might have to
use the package in a different way or
you might have to change to use a
different package right but definitely
prophecy is a great tool and you should
you should use it when you when you hit
this problem and the next one is scaling
up right so the next solution is you get
bigger machines which Joe presented and
also Darvey on our previous session
mentioned one great great way of scaling
up is by saying hey if I have a bigger
machine somewhere now you can use our
studio pro job launcher to run that
particular instance on a machine with
more resources for me personally I work
last year on a on a package called cloud
ml and it was intended to take your your
deep learning model package it up and
send it to Google Cloud Train it and
then get the results what I've seen on
the github issues is that a lot of
people are actually using this not for
deep learning but just in general for
modeling which is totally fine like you
don't need to use it for deep learning
if you don't want to and in general
there's multiple ways of scaling up this
talk is about scaling out which means if
if you're scaling up and you know you
feel like a ceiling on the compute power
that you that you have access to or if
you simply have a lot of machines pair
to use what can you do to take advantage
of all all those machines and that's
where sparked see
now this this slide is not you know
fully comprehends if there's many more
many other ways of scaling up and
scaling out but at least that's the
context of how how you would usually
scale scale out and for those of you
that prefer diagrams this is how it
looks like right you can scale up or
scale vertically or you can scale out or
horizontally basically by adding
machines it does mean that you need to
install spark on each machine on this
cluster but once you have spark running
on each machine you can basically run in
this case a linear regression across all
the machines without having to manually
run you know a subset of the data and
then figure out how to aggregate it so
how do how do you use R with spark well
first of all sparkly R is an R package
you need to insulate from cran and the
second step is you need to install spark
on that particular machine you wrought
you install it just by running Spartan
style pretty straightforward and then
you connect by saying spark connect
master equals local with with sparkly
are you can very easily work locally by
specifying the parameter master equals
local but you can also run on a variety
of cluster providers like data breaks
IBM Microsoft and Google or on-premise
like cloud era and map R and zerah so
definitely you know it's the same
interface you work with it locally
pretty easily and then you can change
this parameter and connect to a proper
cluster when needed
one of the design philosophies that we
follow and sparkly R was to be as
friendly to your community as possible
so we try not to reinvent the wheel so
if you already know how to use the plier
you can use the plier with sparkly R if
you want to use sequel with the dbi
package you can also as well just run a
DB get query and get data out of
sparking in parallel with the ease of
use of our not only that but you can
also do modeling and we have a beyond
like 50 feature transformers and
modeling tools available in spark and
you can access them from sparkly R with
ease one of the features that we worked
on last year was introducing pipelines
which Kevin Cole presented last year and
pipelines allow you to take those work
that you have already completed on your
on your modeling step and allows you to
export them to production what's new in
spark we covered a streaming last year
we worked on M leap which basically
allows you to take a pipeline and export
it out of spark and put it into any java
compatible environment that runs the JVM
we added support for kubernetes and a
little bit of our studio two point one
point two integration so you have some
of the great features of our studio 1.2
are also available when using spark like
you can create a custom query sequel
query or you can use the job spin just
to track your spark jobs and then reopen
the job on spark
what are we currently working on we're
mainly working on to two big features
one is support for Apache ro and the
other one is extra boost on spark so
what is Apache ro well was did I'm very
much better job explaining this this
morning but you know the one-liner is ro
is a cross language developed platform
for foreign memory data really the only
thing that matters to you in I think in
an ideal world that you don't even need
to know what ro is and we just want to
make things faster for you and that's
exactly what what would what we're
trying to accomplish so you should be
able to include the library arrow and
then sparkly R and get performance
improvements so let's take a quick look
at to see how that looks like
yeah so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna start another spark instance and
so this is connecting again locally and
then we're simply gonna go and process
10,000 records that's not that much
usually the first time takes a little
bit longer because the spark is warming
up but it's just 10,000 rows which is
not that much this this computer only
has two cores and I think it gigabytes
of RAM so nothing nothing fancy at all
so we're processing these data set and
you know it just takes nine seconds then
next time you take a little bit it
should be a little bit faster but what
is crazy is that once once you run this
with arrow which is not on cron yet it's
being underdeveloped on active
development and once you run it with era
we're processing 1 million rows so just
not ten thousand one hundred times more
data and is we're doing that on for a
second so that is that is just I don't
even understand how how these can be
possible but it's just it's just great
so really hoping that you don't you
don't have to worry much about arrow but
at least while using sparkley are that
you're gonna get these performance
improvements and the other feature that
we're working on is extra boost on spark
so you're gonna be able to train extra
boost models and spark and this is
exactly what we're doing here it's
basically training
it's like extension that Kevin who is
working on and you know it trains
basically a model using extra boost and
what is great about this is that the
next talk we're gonna introduce ml flow
which is relevant to this case because
I'm basically living a model for caring
to decide if he wants to use it on his
talk and he's gonna teach you how to how
to share models you know in a big data
science team find back my presentation
right so we covered those two and with
that I just want to say thank you and
leave you with some resources so thank
you
awesome thank you so much heavy air so
we do have time for a couple questions
if anybody has some you're gonna stand
on the right side of the room here
so I have a question about arrow that
that seemed really cool you just load
the library that you don't have to like
call and call and call that library it's
Park will sparkly are well automatically
like look for era being installed yeah
yeah I mean in general I don't know if
you know I'm not expert in arrow but
like the way the way I see it is arrow
is like a technology that provides you
know support for developers so you know
like the fact that I'm using arrow
should be mostly transferring to you but
you know yeah to you like you shouldn't
change anything and in fact we also get
we're looking forward to our occurs it
should also give us some free features
currently sparkly are doesn't support
nested data you know there's some
restrictions around that so by having a
cross-platform that can enable multiple
technologies like features like struck
nested data should should should become
a free feature that we get on sparkly
are just by using arrow which is which
is great
hi thank you um you demonstrated in the
right here you demonstrated the the
spark tasks as real-time you call it on
demand in our and it worked and then it
stopped you know it just it ran and then
it stopped do you have the capability to
do the process push the tasking straight
to spark and then return to the console
where you can then use the result from
that you know an economic multi node
spark topology sorry I'm not sure if I
follow the question okay well so you've
got one you're pulling from one topic
you do something to it then you maybe
you push it back into another topic and
then you do something else another task
is pulling from that topic seems like
everything to do in there is is pulling
from a spark topic or kafka topic and
then doing stuff locally are you pushing
tasks to spark so that work continues to
do that tasks while you doing other
things right like that's that's the
whole point of these so especially on
the shiny app like the shiny app
actually takes this the raw stream which
you know if you're using a cluster you
basically have like multiple machines
apalling from Kafka and this the stream
is actually processed in parallel you
know like when you do the aggregations
and when you do the filtering that's
actually happening in the cluster and
you you're the one that choose that
chooses what data either gets collected
to the driver node which we you
obviously don't want to collect a lot of
data but also you you have the option of
just pushing back to some other stream
so you can you know connect it back to a
Kafka queue for output or you can put it
on a dashboard and definit you need to
be careful which data you end up
collecting but there is no restriction
as to how much data you process as long
as the destination can handle that much
data right so that's yeah
[Music]